[Music]
I have with me of a nickel
the CEO of deutsche glass father from
germany movie thanks for speaking to us
today let's start by you telling me a
bit about the company and what you do
yeah sure thanks for having me Brian
deutsche glass father was is basically
the fastest-growing FTTH company in
germany I think we separate a little bit
from the other models as a wholesale
only provider because we are actually
offering end customer product to
residential customers so I think that's
a little bit different than the others
was wholesale only approach but on top
of that I mean you ask a little bit
about the history our history lies in
the Netherlands our history was the
company reggae fiber in the Netherlands
which built more than 2 million FTTH
households here which was sold to kpn
and then my Dutch colleagues basically
opened deutsche glass was a branch in
germany and really revolutionised in
rural areas the way we look at FTTH and
bandwidth to rural areas
that's quite a track record tell me why
then people should come to you for the
ref tth networks i think first of all i
think from a price bandwidth perspective
we have the best product in the market
so we retired for instance at the
hundred megabit product and our minimum
bandwidth for residential customers is
200 megabit 400 megabit and 600 megabit
and when you do a price comparison our
400 megabit product is actually cheaper
over for the first two years then the
250 megabit product of Deutsche Telekom
super vectoring with copper I think
that's a lot of I would say stimulus to
come to our network and the rest is
basically when you have a fiber
connection in your house you think about
about the real estate prices will be
enlarged by having a fiber connections
these are all things where we bring
bandwidth where no bandwidth was
the past absolutely just well I've got
you what's your view on on subsidizing
fiber you know what's your opinion about
that yeah I think there are certain
areas right sports where it's from a
private investor perspective it's not
viable to build out there and I think
that's the area where state funds should
focus focus on and state they should be
deliberately focused on that in the rest
I would strongly argue that state funds
or state aid should not slow down
private investment there's enough money
at the moment in the market to roll out
privately funded companies but this is
an add-on this is not basically private
versus state aid okay well thank you
very much for talking to us today you
for having me
[Music]
you